your mom's quite into the tough love
isn't she she's she's a beast man she's
amazing love and care but she don't care
she it's the reason why she's just like
I remembered it was a time I think my
first play at a roll call and then like
it was pressed night I was out our mom
this is the casting director this is the
woman who basically the reason why I got
in a room and this is to any yoga and
she was like when you're gonna give him
another job when you give him another
job it's not going uni he's not going
you need give him when she's a car
there's some stuff coming up she was
sponsored as well I took her today to
get out premiere and then like it was in
the car I was chilly and everyone was
always good and then like and I was like
oh yeah mum what do you what do you
think about my American accent she was
like nearly there this is the woman you
were bringing to the Oscars with you
yeah after you man that's the fun
okay I wanted to meet random people the
other day all my life for playing Snoop
Dogg out loud yeah and when she man
she's like giggling so funny you're all
gonna be there yeah because you're
Swedish how does that work cuz obviously
you're married to an Irishman now so so
are you learning Irish are you learning
Irish phrases even I was just actually
quite close a lot of people think that
I'm Irish because in Sweden I guess we
have the same arse
mm-hmm yeah this is a bit of a
connection and it's new learning Swedish
phrases I wish it was better actually
one thing that he likes is he came to
Sweden and he learned that it's a lot of
we have a lot of Swedish sayings that
are very commonly used and it's one of
those things when it's my own language I
didn't really think about how weird they
are but he learned about them and he was
like I'm just now gonna use those and
it's like saying in Swedish well now
you're taking a poop in the blue cabinet
yeah it's like a very common thing or
like yeah you can't just expect yourself
you know to walk in here like sliding in
on a shrimp sandwich politicians when I
was back home now and Sweden use that in
a debate in Swedish I was like yeah
that's how you can't come in here and
slide on a shrimp sandwich you know in
an in a socialist country having a
shrimp son which is very fancy so it's
like you can't just have your privileges
and walk in slide in here on a shrimp
sandwich we have an australian one we're
not here to [ __ ] spiders
let's get on with it it'd be difficult
[Music]
you